as the casualty count mounts in ukraine
as the chinese communist party begins
ratcheting up the aggression in taiwan
as the post-cold war world order seems
to be on the brink of collapse the biden
administration wants to make sure that
you don't get distracted from the real
threat
global warming
hopefully president putin would realize
that in the northern part of his country
they used to live on 66 percent of a
nation that was over frozen land
now it's thawing
and his infrastructure is at risk
and the people of russia at risk and so
i hope president putin will help us to
stay on track with respect to what we
need to do for the climate
yes that'll stop putin the man currently
shelling civilians and killing children
in ukraine the world leader famous for
assassinating journalists and poisoning
his political opponents with nerve
agents the ex-kgb spy who openly brags
about his ambition to reassemble the
soviet union once known as the evil
empire that man
is going to call off his soldiers
out of fear of greta thundberg and the
sun monster so hopes john kerry and the
biden administration and the scariest
part of all
is that john kerry just might be the
most lucid tactician in the entire
administration i'm michael knowles this
is the michael nola show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from jay mace who
says i spent all morning yelling at
people who voted for joe biden but then
i got cold so i left the cemetery yes
it's very chilly you can't spend all
that time talking to those biden voters
uh uh
things are the way they are okay things
are getting
a little unstable here on the domestic
front on the foreign funds
certainly economically you're going to
want to protect what's yours which is
why i would recommend you check out
birch gold right now no matter what
you're doing text knolls
k-n-o-w-l-e-s to 9-8-9-8-9-8
do it because 40 years ago ronald reagan
saw a massive inflation unlike anything
the country had ever seen before until
today in reagan's own words inflation is
as violent as a mugger as frightening as
an armed robber and as deadly as a
hitman right now your retirement
accounts are under attack thanks to the
inflationary policies of this
administration that's why you got to
call birch gold the only people i trust
to help you diversify your 401ks and
iras into gold if you don't do that you
are missing the boat okay you're
actually you're treading water without a
life vest birch gold has your life vest
i really have enjoyed investing in
precious metals it's worked out pretty
well for me and especially now with the
dollar going all over the place let them
help you convert an ira or 401k into a
tax sheltered ira in gold they've got
thousands of satisfied customers a plus
rating from the better business bureau
text knolls to 98 98 98 to get a free
info kit on gold reagan knew the biggest
threat to your wealth protect yours now
text knolls to 98 98.98 canon wles to
get your free info kit now
i'm not joking when i say john kerry
who who believes that fear of the sun
monster and a swedish child yelling at
him will stop vladimir putin from
conquering ukraine i'm not
exaggerating or lying when i say john
kerry is one of the more reasonable sane
people in the administration when we're
talking about tactics on this russia
ukraine situation
the
secretary of state
anthony blinken has been making the
rounds just what are we doing how is
diplomacy working how are the sanctions
going to work and he was asked a very
simple question
what sanctions are you placing on russia
how are you going to squeeze
vladimir putin in the russian economy to
to resolve this situation in ukraine and
what is that going to mean for americans
and the secretary of state wants to
reassure everybody that the sanctions
are going to do absolutely nothing
russia's economy is fueled by gas and
the u.s is a consumer so would the u.s
consider cutting off oil and gas
purchases from russia
well what we're doing nora across the
board is making sure that we inflict
maximum pain
on russia for what president putin has
done while minimizing any of the pain uh
to us we're in full coordination with uh
with other countries both consumers and
producers alike to minimize any impact
that this may have on on energy prices
and on gasoline
okay hold on hold on a second here
because you'll notice secretary of state
blinken did not answer the question
it was it was a pretty good question
actually and he didn't answer it though
i think the fact that he didn't answer
it means that he actually did answer it
she asks him the reporter asks him
are we going to go after russia's oil
and gas
russia makes all of its money on oil and
gas
now america consumes a lot of oil and
gas so if you go after russia's oil and
gas that's going to hurt putin but it's
going to also hurt the americans who are
filling up their tanks it's going to
disproportionately hurt poor americans
right we all need to fill up the tanks
of our cars and so people who have less
money if the price of oil and gas goes
up people who need to not just fill up
their tanks but also heat their homes we
use oil for a whole lot of stuff all
consumer goods are going to go up in
price if if we if we
see oil and gas prices go up so it's
going to disproportionately hurt poorer
americans but it's going to hurt all
americans
how are you going to do that buddy
and he says well what we want to do we
want to really hurt putin but we don't
want to in any way hurt the american oil
consumer well that's not possible right
so how are you going to do it
well thankfully the deputy national
security adviser to joe biden gives a
blunter answer and it's the answer we
all suspected when we heard blink and
run his mealy mouth which is
they're not going to do anything
targeting the russian energy industry is
totally off the table is that what
you're saying believe
what i'm saying is that our measures
were not designed to disrupt in any way
the current flow of energy from russia
to the world now
we have also said we're going to cut off
russia's access to cutting-edge
technology that technology can be used
across many sectors
uh and and so as it relates to russia's
long-term productive capacity
we are seeking to degrade that capacity
but nothing nothing in the short term as
it relates to energy
no we want to reassure the world we are
not in any way going to hurt russia's
only industry you know the only industry
that gives putin his money with which to
wage the war in ukraine we're not we're
not going to touch that but we are going
to leverage some
some pretty heavy sanctions on russian
haberdashers yeah oh yeah buddy
you're it's going to be bad
russian trinket makers
russian ice cream parlors
oh yeah we're going after them hard but
the oil and gas industry which funds the
entire country as john mccain said one
of the few
precise things that and accurate things
that john mccain observed is that russia
is a gas station with a country attached
they they're just entirely reliant on
oil and gas yeah we're not going to
touch that
that'll show you putin no no don't worry
it's okay greta thundberg and john kerry
are going to yell at putin so that's
going to stop the war okay okay buddy oh
my gosh
how do these people how do these people
make it to such
positions of power
it's a
it's a simple problem actually that
they're dealing with which is they don't
want to make any decisions
they know that any decision you make
especially when you're talking about
the presidential level of politics any
decision that you make is going to help
some people and hurt other people
there are no easy decisions that make it
to the presidential level if it goes all
the way up there
you're dealing with really really
difficult problems and they don't want
to deal with that because they're
extremely immature and irresponsible and
living in a fantasy world these are the
kind of people who can't tell the
difference between men and women
they don't think you even have to make a
decision there
they don't think that you no it's listen
if you're a man maybe you can be a woman
if you're a woman maybe you can be a man
actually actually you don't even need to
be a man or a woman you can be any of
the other 57 genders that's fine is it
any wonder that these people can't make
the simple decision no
we're going to sanctio if we're going to
sanction russia we're going to sanction
russia
when donald trump sanctioned russia what
did he do did he go after the the
russian russian garments association no
he went after the pipeline he went after
nordstrom 2. and it worked by the way
russia did not launch a full invasion of
ukraine during the trump administration
and does that lead to some problems at
home
maybe not if you catch it early enough
by the way does that cause some
consternation in europe yeah maybe it
does but donald trump donald trump laid
it out for europe he said hold on we're
paying for your military so that you can
go pay russia to go give you your energy
we're paying for your military
specifically
because you're afraid that russia is
going to invade you
and then what are you doing you're
taking all those savings all that money
that we're allowing you to save by
paying for your military and you're
giving it to russia to get your energy
that's not going to work we're not going
to do that okay
we're protecting germany we're
protecting france we're protecting all
of these countries
and then numerous of the countries go
out and make a pipeline deal with russia
where they're paying
billions of dollars into the coffers of
russia
so we're supposed to protect you against
russia but they're paying billions of
dollars to russia and i think that's
very inappropriate and the former
chancellor of germany is the head of the
pipeline company that's applying the gas
ultimately germany will have almost 70
percent
of their country
controlled by
russia with natural gas so you tell me
is that appropriate i mean i've been
complaining about this
from the time i got in it should have
never been allowed to have happened
but germany is totally controlled by
russia because they will be getting from
60 to 70 percent of their energy
from russia and a new pipeline and you
tell me if that's appropriate because i
think it's not and i think it's a very
bad thing for nato and i don't think it
should have happened
what happened when donald trump posed
that problem to to russia the the
mainstream media in the united states
said
he's undermining nato
donald trump is undermining nato
not at all he was strengthening nato
he was
strengthening nato by weakening russia
but now we've got the worst of all
worlds because this administration
doesn't want to make any choices
no one does every no one is thinking
about the broader strategic picture or
the common good they're all just
thinking about themselves summed up
perfectly by joy behar on the view who
said you know the worst part of this
whole ukraine issue
what's going to happen to my roman
holiday
estimates are 50 000 ukrainians will be
dead or wounded and that this is going
to start a humanitarian crisis a refugee
crisis in europe we're talking about
five million people
that that are going to be displaced yeah
i mean
it's it's heartbreaking to hear what is
going to happen yeah well i'm scared of
what's going to happen in in western
europe too yeah you know you just you
plan a trip you want to go there i want
to go to italy for four years i haven't
been able to make it because of
of uh the pandemic and now this you know
it's like who's gonna what's gonna
happen there
when when joy bahar started saying this
i thought it was the setup to a joke
you know yeah and you know the real
problem is i i don't get to stay at my
tuscan villa this summer and i didn't
even get to last year either
but it wasn't she was dead she was 100
serious
and this is instructive this is how
our elites
think
i'm not just talking about the elites in
government i'm talking about the alien
government media like joy behar the
elites in private industry
they're not thinking about
the national good they're not even
thinking about the global humanitarian
good they're just thinking about numero
uno
you know you know gosh this really
teaches me about suffering because i fee
i feel bad for those children being
shelled in kiev right now but but i
might not even get to go to the uffizi
this summer
can you you know it's suffering right
hey ain't that just the way suffering
works
and when you want to protect yourself
not even just your physical self but
your your identity i strongly recommend
you check out lifelock right now go to
lifelock.com
knowles do it okay your personal data
are always at risk of being stolen
during the recent lockdowns cyber
attacks have been evolving they're
getting more elaborate some things you
can do to help protect yourself from
cyber crime include using two-factor
authentication
creating unique passwords for each
online account it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every
single day
we put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could steal what's yours sometimes
harming your your finances your credit
your reputation good thing there's
lifelock they detect a whole range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised they'll
send you an alert you've got a dedicated
restoration specialist if you become a
victim no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can help protect
what's yours with lifelock by norton
join today save up to 25 off your first
year lifelock.com knowles that is
lifelock.com knowles for 25 percent off
forget john kerry
forget
greta thundberg
forget
joe biden's fake sanctions that aren't
actually going to stop any industry in
russia or squeeze putin at all
the left has one more strategy here to
stop vladimir putin
this one i think actually has the best
chance of doing it
slam poetry
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
if i was your mother you would have been
so loved
held in the arms of joyous light
never would the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky if i was your mother
the world would have been warm
so much laughter and joy and nothing
would harm i can't imagine the stain the
soul stealing pain that the little boy
you must have seen and believed and the
formulation of thought quickly taught
that you lived in a cruel unjust world
is this why
you now decide no one will get the best
of you
is this why you do not hide nor away shy
from taking back the world it was it
because so early in life all that strife
wrapped your little body with fear
two more minutes of this i would be
willing to turn over my family i would
surrender my entire country this is
psychological warfare i believe this is
prohibited by the geneva convention so
torturous is it
people are making fun of this this
actress anna lynn mccord
for her story if putin were actually
strapped down to a gurney and made to
watch this i promise you he would stop
the war in ukraine
so painful is it in the words of harold
bloom the late great literary critic
slam poetry is the death of art
the death of art the death of foreign
policy apparently as well the saddest
thing about this little viral clip of
this actress reading her slam poem to
vladimir putin
her strategy is no less effective
than john kerry's
what her strategy is hey
hey
vlad
i think you're acting really bad and you
need to stop being so mad and invade
ukraine it's insane
maine
right that's that's her strategy here's
john kerry's strategy
it's gonna get really hot vladimir
no not because of our weapons we're not
gonna fire any weapons or anything but
because of the sun so stop please
because of the sun monster
and here's here's joe biden's actual
official strategy from the white house
hey vladimir putin we're go we're not
going to let people buy
russian
toy dolls anymore you know those
stacking dolls where it's the doll and
you open there's like 10 more dolls
inside the doll we're not going to let
people they can still buy your oil but
we're not going to let them buy those
dolls anymore
all of those strategies are equally
effective
they don't do anything
we are our our nation is being led
by the slam poetry actress lady
it's it's just it's just a lot of the
slam poetry actress lady wearing suits
with really serious faces and and you
know really prim and proper haircuts but
it's exactly
as effective
there we have been so hollowed out
morally
intellectually politically economic
we've been so hollowed out
i i don't know that we are we are
capable of serious international action
anymore
we had a reprieve during the trump
administration
he actually was
was pretty good on the international
front
but donald trump was the was the bull in
the china shop where donald trump is in
no way the foreign policy establishment
that generally speaking runs
our foreign policy and by the way he
ended up getting run out by the deep
state anyway
so he was the exception not the rule the
rule is really
pathetic how did we get so hollowed out
in part i think i've said this before
about tick-tock you know we always play
tick-tock videos here to show you what
the youths are listening to
i would not be surprised if i discovered
that tiktok
were just a russian psychological or
russian a chinese psychological
operation to hollow out america i would
not be surprised at all i feel that way
about a lot of social media
well there was a really brilliant idea
just came up in the wall street journal
saw this article yesterday i think it's
great in an article by thomas lehrman
and brad wilcox the idea is no instagram
or tick tock without parental consent
okay no what does that mean well look if
if
if i want to go on a if i wa if i'm a
teacher and i want to take my students
on a field trip what do i have to do i
need to give a permission slip out and
the parents or guardian need to sign the
permission slip and say okay my kid can
go on the field
trip there are a whole host of
activities for which you need a little
permission slip if you want a kid to be
able to do it then there are a lot of
activities that kids are not even
permitted to engage in
well how come they're allowed to go on
instagram and tick tock this just gaping
whole pathway straight to hell where
there is all sorts of insane content i'm
not just talking about the obscenity and
the porn that's on these on these
channels i'm talking about the weird
creepy ideological stuff that's going to
convince your kid little johnny that
he's really little jane and convince him
that he his country is evil and all
sorts of really wacky ideology
obviously there should be a permission
slip now this seems to me to be a pretty
fair middle ground compromise between on
the one hand the licentious animals who
think that little kids need to be able
to do whatever they want they should go
to drag queen story hour and that's a
blessing of liberty and then on the
other hand the conservatives who think
this stuff should just be banned and
tick tock should just be banned and
pornography should not even just be age
limited but just bam just just get rid
of it
that's what we did for most of american
history let's just go back to that right
that would be that would be much more
what i'm interested in right i'm just
saying this let's let's get back to a
semi-reasonable kind of national policy
nobody benefits from allowing
creepy grooming drag queens to go on
tick-tock and pervert your kid's mind so
let's just get rid of it okay but let's
we're not ready for that let's have a
middle ground you need a permission slip
for this stuff how do you do it
uh instagram's not going to do it by
itself instagram tick tock all of these
social media companies are preying on
your child they're finding the most
the the weakest parts of your child's
psychology the most vulnerable aspects
of their mind and they're gunning for
those and their algorithms are feeding
those there have been huge reports on
this feeding eating disorders feeding
all sorts of psychological disorders and
pathologies because it gets more clicks
it keeps the eyeballs on the screen
longer and that way they get to sell you
more things from their advertisers and
they get to collect more data from your
kids so that's that's what the media
companies are going to keep doing how
about we use our political power and our
elected representatives to go in and say
no you can't do that sorry you need a
permission slip fine by me it's a middle
ground compromise i would much rather go
in with a wrecking ball knock down these
woke big tech companies servers and then
plow the ground with salt where they
once stood but if if you think that's a
little too far right wing for right now
okay i'm willing to grant maybe that's
the case at the very least we need the
permission slips we need limits okay
this gets to something i talked about
yesterday i got to it at the very end of
the show but i don't want to i don't
want to just skip over it this is really
important
there's a new report out from the center
for immigration studies
the united states
population
of legal and illegal immigrants has now
reached an all-time high that's 46.6
million
immigrants in the united states this is
up 1.6 million since joe biden was
inaugurated
it's a huge increase it's just a huge
percentage and it's just too many
immigrants okay
part of my family
were immigrants the italian side part of
the family came on the mayflower and
they were here from the very beginning
but part of my family came basically on
a sardine boat from sicily and they were
immigrants so i'm not i don't i have a
problem with immigrants per se i'm sure
lots of these immigrants legal ones and
frankly some of the illegal ones i'm
sure they're very nice people but
you can't just replace
the population of a country with lots of
foreigners who have no connection to
your national rituals your beliefs your
traditions
your language
who are who are not part of the people
of the country and expect to have the
same country it's not possible you can't
assimilate
50 million people overnight
period you can't do that at all and you
can't expect to have the same country
that you would have afterwards okay it's
not
it's not possible just like right now
it's not possible when you go to the
brick and mortar auto parts store to
find a lot of the parts you're looking
for which is why you got to check out
rock auto right now go to
rockauto.com
you can see every part available for
your car or truck write knolls in the
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we sent you right now on your
person you have got multiple ways
to go to rock auto to get all the parts
that you need for your car or truck you
got your phone you got your laptop maybe
you got your ipad it's so easy rather
than driving to the brick and mortar
store where you go you drive there it
takes what 10 15 minutes you go you wait
in line it takes however long they you
get peppered with questions what what
make and model is it the 2009 gtz civic
or the whatever then you answer the
questions they go in the back they don't
have the parts there's so many parts to
stock these days they say oh we're gonna
have to order it come back in a week you
drive don't do that rockauto.com they've
got
the best most reliably low prices no
gimmicks they're just always reliably
low same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers the website's so easy
to navigate even i can do it that's
pretty amazing i'm not the handiest guy
in the world when it comes to these
logistical things go to rockauto.com
right now check out all those parts
write knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in that how did you hear about us box
tell them that we sent you you can thank
me later
for many years the republican line
even the conservative movement line on
immigration
was
we don't want illegal immigration but we
want lots of legal immigration
right we don't
illegal is bad legal is good and there
should be no limits to legal immigration
even donald trump donald trump is the
most right-wing conservative rock-ribbed
president of my lifetime he said i want
more legal immigration than ever i love
immigration but it's got to be done the
legal way
no that's wrong that's the wrong line
okay
i don't
i don't besmirch anybody's reputation i
don't i don't think that people engaged
in this kind of talk necessarily with
bad intentions but it's crazy
if there's no limit then what okay we've
got 330 million people in america what
let's just bring in 330 million people
next year
we've already got 46 so let's say the
majority of america is just foreigners
with no real connection to american
history or tradition
would that be a good idea would you
support that no of course not you you
wouldn't help the immigrants exactly in
some ways you would i guess but you
would completely destroy america so the
place they're coming to wouldn't really
exist anymore
because america is not just an idea it's
a place and it's a people with
traditions and connections and rituals
and a language so you can't do that
you've got to have some kind of limit
the limitless immigration thing it's
it's the same as the joy behar problem
the the problem is that the ruling elite
have been governing without any thought
toward the common good without any
thought toward the national good they've
been thinking about the good of their
own pockets
and their own success at the ballot box
the democrats support limitless
immigration legal and illegal
because immigrants broadly not just
illegal but legal too are
likely to vote for democrats so the
democrats like that more immigration
please
and the democrats are opposed generally
to a lot of traditions in america so if
you flood the country with people who
have no connection to those traditions
you're gonna weaken those traditions
okay that's why they like it why do the
republicans like it because for a long
time we're the party of the chamber of
commerce and the chamber of commerce
likes cheap labor and they know that
when you flood the country with
immigrants the the cost of labor
decreases and so they get to fill their
pockets
right so it's
both purely selfish motives without any
thought to the common good actually it
harms the common good
and what do we have we have a country
that's falling apart with little faith
in our institutions little connection to
our past toppling our statues
it barely feels like a country anymore
it's very difficult to project our
influence overseas right now for
instance
because
we don't what do we project we don't
even know what we're projecting
this immigration issue is an important
one
it's not hateful it's not bigoted it's
not even xenophobic or nativist these
kind of silly terms to say that a
country needs to have limits country
needs to have borders country needs to
have a people
that that do things together that have a
national memory a national history
national ritual and practice
means you can't let everybody in
and
it's going to be basically impossible to
teach democrats that lesson at least the
republicans that need to figure it out
there are shifting political wins i will
tell you that cpac is going on right now
i was really hoping that i could be able
to get down there i was planning on
going
very grateful to cpac for the invitation
we couldn't make the logistics work so
maybe next year you know who is going to
see pac though
tulsi gabbard tulsi gabbard who is tulsi
gabbard well you might remember her as a
democrat candidate for president in 2020
but tulsi wasn't
your usual democrat candidate for
president
she's a democrat she's a liberal make no
mistake about that she supports abortion
not in all cases but in a lot of cases
she
supports all sorts of democrat policies
but she broke with the democrats over
their kind of
desiccated corrupt ruling establishment
she was very anti-clinton
she was very anti-war machine even
though kelsey gabbard served in the
military so she's got a lot of
credibility here when we're talking
about
war and foreign policy
so why is tulsi a republican now
it's not really even the issue so much i
think it's
it's a little bit
generational
it's a little bit generational i saw
this is gonna seem like it's not
connected but it actually is on
president's day on washington's birthday
the gop account
posted on instagram a picture of
presidents that it liked and it had all
the hits for the republicans
it had ronald reagan and it said you
know
thank you to all of our not you
presidents who've made america great and
the not you was joe biden and then all
the rest were these republican
presidents
but which republican presidents did they
pick
they picked people like ronald reagan
okay we all like reagan picked people
like donald trump yeah we all like trump
they picked the bushes
they thought you know the bushes that's
great and they left out
presidents like teddy roosevelt he's a
republican
right and that had been the view of the
republican party we're the party of the
bushes
we're the part we hate teddy roosevelt
he was sort of a progressive
he was a conservationist he didn't want
to just destroy all of the natural parks
and environments and just
i don't know create more industry there
we're the bush party and i if you looked
in the comments on instagram there's all
these republicans saying wait hold on
the bushes hold on you have the bushes
over teddy roosevelt what are you
talking about
seems like a minor point but it's
it's more and more evidence of something
we've seen since trump the republican
party is reimagining itself during the
bush years the republican party was the
party of the plutocrats and the big
business and they hate the environment
and they're super pro immigration and
they love bombing the middle east and
they never they never saw war they
didn't want to start
or at least
ratchet up
and the republican party of trump is not
that
we were told that donald trump
was completely changing the republican
party he was making it into something
that's not the opposite is true
the opposite is true donald trump was in
many ways returning the republican party
to what it was when it was founded the
party of lincoln the party up through
teddy roosevelt the party really up
through the
1970s or 80 80s even
he was returning it to something more
traditional now before we get to the
mailbag i do there is some breaking news
which is that
joe biden has made his pick reportedly
for for the supreme court
uh
so his his pick according to reports
from the wall street journal i'll pull
it up right now just got it i got the
the notification on my phone biden plans
to nominate katanji brown jackson to the
supreme court the reason she's
ostensibly the more qualified candidate
for the supreme court there were a few
other people being considered there was
a lot of political pressure from close
biden allies to go with someone else
sajiran's got a sterling resume she's
probably a complete lunatic so that's
too bad
the reason i mention it though as well
is there was a news report yesterday
that the george floyd family lawyer was
really pushing for katanji katanji brown
and i thought okay regard i don't really
care who the nominee is any nominee from
biden is going to be terrible
i thought
why do i care
what the george floyd family lawyer
thinks about the supreme court why do i
care
what the lawyer for the family of this
career criminal who has been turned into
the greatest saint in american history
because he was killed while resisting
arrest in a police altercation while
committing a crime why do i care how
how perverse has our judicial process
become
and our and our process of government
even when we're talking about naming the
judges
that that sort of thing
is important does not this this not this
nomination for the supreme court has
been sort of poisoned from the beginning
because joe biden said he's not going to
pick the most qualified candidate he's
he's really only looking at race and sex
which is
ugly to most americans it's repulsive to
most americans more and more evidence so
he picked the candidate who's probably
most qualified okay i can only imagine
in a way i don't want the most qualified
candidate from from joe biden because it
means that that person is going to be
extremely intelligent and capable and
clever and probably better at getting
her way but that's the news you know
it's more important than ever to
understand just how insidious the
foreign threats are within our own
country
we have just the way for you to do it
our new show the enemy within is a
docu-series featuring a claimed
journalist and expert in national
threats lee smith in the fourth episode
lee describes how the nba has come to
depend on china for much of its profit
and as a result how the nba and its
players have become a mouthpiece for ccp
propaganda also you got to make sure to
check out ben shapiro's new show the
search his second episode features his
good friend and highly lauded historian
neil ferguson these two great series are
exclusive to daily wire members if
you're not currently a member go to
dailywire.com subscribe to join and also
you know dailywire is making a ton of
new content including movies including
comedy including docu-series
in our first original movie premiered
last week our new films hyperion uh
which is soon to be released in our
summer blockbuster terror on the prairie
with gina carano they're all coming out
all this great content is available to
daily wire members to make sure to
become one today head on over to
dailywire.com watch to check it all out
we'll be right back with the mailbag
first question in the mailbag from lydia
hey michael you keep talking about how
putin did not invade any sovereign
nations while trump was in office
because trump was too unpredictable and
while i agree with that i've been
struggling with the fact that china
invaded hong kong in 2020 despite trump
being in office is there a serious
difference here sincerely sen papira
oh there is a difference first of all
china already had hong kong the british
gave hong kong back to china over 20
years ago what 1999 i think something
like that so so they they already had it
that's a
categorically different situation than
what you have in in taiwan which is
ostensibly still independent and free at
least more so than hong kong has been
the the encroachment into hong kong has
been more gradual but but let's even
grant the premise for a second
let's say that the situations were
comparable
i'm i never suggested that no one was
ever going to test donald trump
uh because donald trump was
so scary that he completely intimidated
every threat around the world
he was unpredictable and so these these
foreign hostile leaders had to make
their own risk calculation
i'm sure a lot of people
thought that donald trump was not really
going to deploy forces in fact donald
trump ran as one of the most anti-war
candidates
in
recent history certainly is the most
anti-war republican we've had in a long
time
right he said the iraq war was terrible
he didn't want to send our kids overseas
he wanted to focus on america first and
wanted to give up global empire so if
you just heard that if you were putin or
or xi jinping you would say okay well
it's time for me to go in and i'll take
ukraine and i'll take taiwan
respectively
but the thing about trump is
every so often he'd just shoot some
missiles
into syria or into afghanistan or or
every so often you'd have a little
rocket man a name given to kim jong-un
by by donald trump you'd have him say
you know i've got a nuclear button i
keep the nuclear button on my desk at
all times and and then what does
what does donald trump do does he go to
a podium he says listen we should not
use this kind of rhetoric we need to
tone down here and no he sends out a
tweet he says yeah little rocket man's
got a button on his desk well he should
know that i've got a button too and
mine's a lot bigger and mine's a lot
more effective and mine actually works
the international community says what is
this maniac doing he's going to start a
nuclear war on twitter
and if you're vladimir putin
when you hear that you say you know
maybe i'll hold off on kiev
maybe i'll just stay in crimea for now
because this guy
this
game show host reality tv star real
estate mogul
tweeting maniac
he might just do it
he might just freaking do it xi jinping
he says well look maybe i'll go a little
further into hong kong and then what
does trump do trump starts clobbering
him with tariffs starts a massive trade
war that poses huge risks to the united
states xi thought that would never
happen
they thought because for 20 years you
had people including joe biden
especially joe biden saying we want
china in the international community we
want a rising china's good for everybody
let them into the world trade
organization who cares if they violate
the treaties who cares if they steal our
ip who cares if they illegally subsidize
stealing aluminum that's okay we want a
rising china trump says no trump used a
lot of salty language that this is a
family show so i'm not going to repeat
and he goes in and he starts a massive
trade war it's very unpredictable and
it's
it's an example of
china calls trump's bluff it turns out
it's not a bluff
and then what happens china releases a
virus that shuts down the world for a
couple of years
perhaps
accidentally perhaps not accidentally
but don't people forget this because we
all focus only on kovid don't forget we
were winning that trade war with china
before code that happened so anyway
these leaders are making their risk
calculations and the key here is not
even to be the most aggressive or on the
flip side to be the most dovish the key
here is
be unpredictable from matthew dear mr
knowles you seem to be an educated and
very well-read man thank you matthew i'm
handsome too i'm so well we're
complimenting me i'll take everything
you got as such my questions relate to
some of the founding texts of western
literature namely the trade the trojan
epics
uh homer's iliad and odyssey virgil's
knee at first which one is your favorite
and why second how should one go about
reading them just dive in with the iliad
or read some other sources to gain some
context love the show keep up the good
work well i'm partial to the aeneid
because the aneed inspired my favorite
poem which is the divine comedy by dante
but if you told me just right now you're
going to sit down and read all of these
what's your favorite i would probably
say the odyssey
is my favorite it includes uh
one of my fav favorite lines from
telemachus who says it's a wise man who
knows his own father that's just a
really salty funny line and it's just a
wonderful story so how would i dive into
reading them i would pick up
an annotated copy
and i would read it and i would read all
the notes
this is really important speaking of
dante when you're reading dante one
problem that people have with reading
dante is he has so many literary and
political illusions that people just
don't get these days unless you're a
medieval florentine you're not going to
get some of them
so you need an annotated copy
so get a good nice thick one for dante
it's the durling martinez there are
other good translations and annotated
versions of the iliad the odyssey and
the anion i like the fagles but there
are others so get a critical edition
just read all the notes and you'll get
it it's going to be plotting and
plotting and plotting and the first time
you're going to need all the notes and
maybe even the second time you read it
you're gonna need all the notes and then
you're gonna be able to really really
enjoy it that's what i would do
i don't think you need to go necessarily
take a course or read in any particular
order just jump in whatever grabs you i
i don't really care for the iliad as
much as the odyssey so the odyssey comes
after the iliad but you know for me i
would go for the odyssey first your
mileage may very go
part of reading
is
erotic okay you know sometimes people
say old books are sexy books actually
are sexy and this is
an important thought
on on how to pursue education
alan bloom in the closing the american
mind says that education is so sterile
kind of like our relationships we don't
have love affairs anymore we have
relationships i'm in a relationship with
my partner oh that sounds hot that's
about as hot as an accounting firm no
you're supposed to be in love you're
supposed to be drawn dante talks about
this
where where we are drawn to grow in
wisdom and maturity should should be a
sort of erotic thing we turn our loves
our natural desires toward the good we
perfect our loves and and then then we
grow so if if you have an attraction to
a story let's say it's the odyssey you
should pursue that if you have an
attraction toward adventure stories you
could either waste all your time
watching stupid marvel movies or you
could turn it towards something that
will be a little bit more edifying so do
that don't suppress your desire don't
deny your desire but turn turn your
desire in a way that's going to be more
edifying from kelsey i need the love
guru
speaking of eros
i'm a 29 year old woman with a beautiful
eight-year-old son when my son was four
i met my boyfriend before things got
serious i said i wanted what i wanted
which consisted of marriage kids and to
follow god he also wanted these things
so it was a great match i love him to
pieces and he's been amazing he stepped
up and became the father my son did not
have
he's raising him to be a good christian
and a good patriot however we've been
together four years and he doesn't seem
to have any future plans marriage which
in turn means children as well as i said
i'm 29 so that the clock is ticking
and he is 44 years old so i feel that
time is not on our side any thoughts i
do have some thoughts
i need to know a little bit more detail
about your situation are you a widow
did you
were you previously married you know to
the maybe the father of your son were
you was the was that a like illicit
mayor like a real marriage were you not
married was it you know you sort of
were impregnated by this guy and then he
was a deadbeat and he ran off so that
those things are gonna matter a little
bit
uh in terms of what you should do now
but all things being equal let's say you
know you
the boyfriend who the first boyfriend
who
gave you your child you know even bad
things can result in good things uh
you know let's say he was a total
deadbeat he ran off you meet this guy he
he really is the father figure to your
son you've been dating four years now i
would tell him
to piss or get off the pot that's what i
would tell them to do
because it's not going to get any easier
men sometimes need a good kick in the
rear
and four years is long enough and if he
doesn't want to marry you and he he
doesn't want to
have more children and he wants to keep
his options open and maybe he wants to
be able to run off at some point then
that's no good
better to rip that band-aid now but
maybe he's a good guy and he just needs
a little encouragement and you should
give him that encouragement
and you can point him to this clip and
say you know my friend michael gave me
that encourage to give you that
encouragement too
from james hello michael i'm a 21 year
old black guy who spent the last couple
of years listening to your show because
i realized how important having some
political knowledge is
i find your show to be a trustworthy
source of it my 16 year old sister has
also recently
dove into politics but for a different
reason her woke crt teaching english
teacher has instilled all the horrors of
america bad and racist ideology into her
she informed me that she doesn't believe
that cracker is a slur against white
people
because white people are the oppressors
not the oppressed she told me i wouldn't
want to vote for a republican unless
they have my values and are not a racist
piece of garbage which is highly
unlikely okay i've challenged her views
a couple of times but i never pushed too
hard for fear of pushing her away since
we used to be very close
i'm just unsure how i should speak to
her or what i should say to convince her
that she and all her friends have been
misled i just don't want to see my
sister turn into the average twitter
user so there's there's two problems
here and they both come back to the same
thing
they both come back to religion
one your sister is obviously steeped in
this
crt ideology
critical race theory
critical race theory derives from
critical theory critical theory derives
from cultural marxism cultural marxism
derives from marx and there are
obviously lots of distinctions along the
way but to quote whitaker chambers the
ex-communist turned conservative marxism
is not the newest ideology in the world
it's the second oldest it began in the
garden of eden when the serpent told
evie ye shall be his gods it is a vision
of the world without god
it's a it's an anti-christian vision of
the world so if you view the world in
this way with the oppressor and the
oppressed and this whole sort of
dialectical view then you're you're
gonna have problems
the second part is
your sister is
viewing herself primarily through the
lens of race
through this religious lens first of all
and then she's grounding her identity
primarily in race that's a big problem
too
not to say that race does not exist not
to say that race doesn't have some
effects in the world but if your
identity is primarily in race you're
going to have a lot of problems
i do not think of myself primarily as
white well i guess i'm not i'm sort of
swarthy i do not think of myself
primarily as swarthy i do not think of
myself primarily as italian primarily as
waspish primarily as english or irish or
welsh or anything like that
i think of myself i don't even think of
myself primarily as an american i'm very
patriotic i love my country deeply i
certainly love my american identity but
primarily i view myself
as christian
i'm a catholic i view myself as a child
of god someone made in the image of god
i i ground my identity in the god who
says my name is i am that i am being
itself
and so i don't get too hung up on the
race stuff or this or that or the other
thing i don't know about your views but
it sounds like you don't view yourself
primarily as a black man i'm a black you
say i'm a black guy but you say that
sort of incidentally you don't say i'm a
black man forget my nation forget my
creator forget my i'm a bl no of course
it's very silly very silly thing to do
so
both of those issues are religious
problems and your sister's gonna have to
sort that out before she can figure out
how completely wrong she is maybe she
could listen to this show
maybe you throw a couple episodes of the
show into your sister's queue and she
figures it out
i hope so or you can just talk to her
from maria hey michael first off i would
love to like to say i love the show
thank you but for business at hand i'm
in a predicament i've been with my
boyfriend for four years and counting
he's the person i want to marry and
spend my life with what is it with this
dating for four years this is i'm seeing
a theme here this is what millennials do
i guess i have certain fantasies and
desires that i don't want to
indulge in
but he wants to talk with me about them
but i feel ashamed for having these
thoughts and feelings to begin with
is this something i should open up to
him about or should i keep this part of
myself locked away sincerely a lady who
wants to lead a virtuous life wow great
question
so what you're saying is i have these
presumably sexual desires that are
disordered that i don't i want at the
lower level of my will i want to indulge
in them you've got some weird sort of
kink or something but at the rational
level i don't want to indulge in them
because they're weird and they're not
virtuous and so i don't want to do it
and he
who's a curious little chap says no come
on tell me about all your weird sexual
desires you're like no i don't want to
do that i don't want to indulge in that
i'd rather
push it to the side
you are right and he is wrong
he is
channeling the wisdom of our age which
is you should never repress anything
especially not a sexual desire but you
are right you should
you should first of all virtue is a
habit so if you the more you indulge
these things the worse they get and the
more you practice the virtues the easier
it becomes to practice the virtues
so it's like anything you know the
the more you smoke cigarettes the easier
it is to smoke cigarettes the harder it
is to stop smoking cigarettes okay and
the same thing when you try to quit the
longer it's been since you quit the
easier it is to go without having a
cigarette
but this gets back to something we
talked about a few questions ago which
is your desires you've got these
disordered desires we all do every
incident a fallen world everybody's got
disordered desires disordered sexual
desires disorder political desires
disordered economic everybody's got
disordered desires
the the key to really overcoming
something like this
is or or at least improving your
situation is not to completely
suppress desire
but to perfect desire to reorder it
so
all desire is pointing towards something
all desire is is evidence of
something good it's it's it wants
something good but the aim sometimes
gets a little bit off
okay and all desire ultimately
should lead back to god so you see this
with dante dante has a crush on this
girl beatrice that he met twice
and he he and he's married to someone
else but he just has this crush on this
girl beatrice and that that's not
necessarily evil and awful and
adulterous if beatrice as she does in
the divine comedy leads dante he
channels his erotic love for her
channels that to bring him to god that's
what you've got to do it's a little bit
pie in the sky it's a little little bit
out there but i think it's also quite
practical as well take those desires
that you've got even if they're a little
bit off and turn them
and and work on turning them and allow
grace to allow them to turn toward the
love that moves the sun and the other
stars i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bourie our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin